first of all i want to pay tribute to
conservative councillors up and down the
land conservative councillors who
have won
those who have sadly
lost and
they do a fantastic job and they deliver
better value
for
lower council tax up and down the
country uh yes you're right uh it's it's
midterm and it's certainly a mixed set
of results and
uh we've had a tough night in some parts
of the of the country but on the other
hand in other parts of the country
you're still seeing uh conservatives
going forward and uh and making uh quite
remarkable gains uh in places that
haven't voted conservative uh for a long
time or if ever
and so
leaving aside the commentary the the big
lesson that i take from this is that
this is a message from voters that what
they want us to do above all one two and
three is focus on the big issues that
matter to them taking the country
forward
making sure that we fix the post covered
economic
aftershocks get us get us all through
coveted through the economic aftershocks
in the way we got through covid
fix the energy supply issues that's
where the inflationary spike is is
coming and keep going with our agenda of
of high wage high skill jobs that's what
we're focused on these are big losses
while westminster wandsworth no
conservative leader in decades has lost
those seats and your neighboring mp here
david simmons he said this morning that
a lot of people were very angry about
you and your law breaking in downing
street and he says you have to face up
to that of course and as i as i say
damian this has been a
a tough night for conservatives in in
some parts of the country and in other
parts of the of the country uh we're
actually moving forward and and so uh
for midterm it's quite interesting that
it's a mixed set of of results and i
think the
the lesson that i take is that
you know and you you you rightly quote
the uh the views from the from the
doorstep but the lesson is
we've got to get on with the stuff that
matters to people we've got to keep uh
delivering on our agenda uh putting 20
000 more police side on the streets
putting getting 50 000 more nurses into
our into our hospitals are continuing
with the biggest program of
infrastructure investment this country
has seen for more than a hundred years
and uniting and leveling up but despite
all of those things the issue on the
doorstep was about cost of living and
just yesterday the bank of england said
we are facing 10
inflation a recession that is all coming
down the track it's not it's not coming
down the track is your high wage uh high
you know job economy what's coming down
the track is much more pain for people
what are you going not what you've done
already but what are you going to do to
address that so that is i think that is
completely right and that's the that's
the lesson that i think we all need to
take what's going on right now is that
the global economy we've seen inflation
spiking in the
in the in the us in in europe uh and in
australia and new zealand and it's
driven by the cost of energy and that is
the thing that we've got to focus on for
decades we failed to invest sufficiently
in uk
domestic energy security we let our
nuclear energy completely collapse we
haven't done enough uh to put in
renewables in the way that we can put in
putting more uh more wind at the scale
and the pace that we can so that is
where we want to go now i'm not going to
pretend to you damien that the uh the
answers well you know that there isn't
going to be
a a difficult period as we come through
uh the aftershocks of covid there is but
what i'm going to tell you is that this
government is absolutely determined to
keep going with every ounce of
compassion and ingenuity that we have
get people through uh the economic
aftershocks help people with the costs
but make sure that we address these
supply side issues particularly energy
in order uh for the economy to keep
growing so
keep going
our solution is a high wage high school
coming down the track what's coming down
the track is recession and 10 inflation
it's going to erode everybody's spending
power but what you could do right now
you say you're going to help everyone
with energy costs one thing you could do
right now is a windfall tax we saw shell
with massive profits yesterday why don't
you do that okay so okay so i saw i had
the head of shell in uh yesterday and i
am the head of uh
a bp uh and uh i i've talked to them
both and and you know
our message to them and and what is very
very clear it's it's
guys you know this is this is a moment
when we need you as a country uh to
invest massively in clean green
renewables in uh in the stuff that is
going to uh make a difference to people
going to reduce prices
and make it what we don't want to do is
make the same mistakes as previous
governments
fail as as i've just been saying fail to
invest in our energy supply so that's
the message that we're giving to the the
big energy companies and it's frankly
better
for them to take that cash put it in
to win farms put it into hydrogen put it
into stuff that will make a big
difference uh to our ability to cope
with uh with the global energy price
spike and above all
make sure that this country is protected
in the future and so that we have more
long-term energy security that's what
we're going for i say well the one thing
about this government is it does
big difficult things and we need to we
need to fix our energy uh supply we can
do it it will take some tough decisions
but in order to do that you need
investment in energy uh supply you need
investment for the long term in uk
nuclear in wheels
is the price all the rest of people's
bills right now that people are worried
about not the future but i wonder why so
but on that don't forget damian what
we're already doing i i appreciate that
and i know i know how tough it is uh to
cope with the with the energy price but
there are things you can so
that's right
we're putting 22 billion pounds of
taxpayers money into support people to
help people uh with the energy price
spike you you know about the council tax
abatement 9.1 billion pounds just to
help with that it's not going to take
that's not going to that's going to give
you a tiny
course and there are other things there
are other things that we're doing but
the point i'm trying to make to you
is that this government
fixed got brexit done i had the fastest
vaccine rollout uh in europe can i ask
you something does something very
beautiful
because i think our viewers were like
know why i'm why i'm taking this
approach i think what the country needs
is a government that will take a big
decision about how to fix uh our energy
supply and you don't do that simply by
clobbering the companies that we need to
make investment uh in
our domestic energy security now that's
that's why we're taking this approach
now one place that this election could
have a very significant result is
northern ireland and we could well see
projections have been going into the
into the vote that shin fein emerge as
the majority
in northern ireland if that happens if
the majority of parties have vote
majority of people have voted for
parties that support
the arrangements that you set up with
the eu the protocol the trading
arrangements
if the majority of people back parties
that support that will you work with
those parties to make that that
arrangement work that protocol those
training arrangements so the most
important thing is that we continue to
support the
the balance of the
the good friday agreement across all
communities in north island that's what
we're going to do
and whatever arrangements we have
they've got to have
cross community support that's what the
good friday agreement is all about
that's what the government is going to
is going to do but as for as for the
rest of it we will have to wait and see
what the what the results are in order
thank you thank you